in this episode of the think media
podcast I'm going to be covering 12
different ways to earn money on YouTube
even if you have a small Channel or
you're just starting I'm also going to
be covering some new ideas that are
available in 2024 that really nobody is
talking about yet and some of the best
opportunities for earning significant
money even with a small following and
some changes that YouTube has made to
the YouTube Partner program but first we
need to Define what even is a small
Channel well when it comes to what's
called influencer marketing there's a
term called micro influencers and Nano
influencers and there's massive
opportunity for those that fit into this
category so micro influencer is widely
understood to have anywhere between
10,000 subscribers up to 100,000
subscribers now you might be in that
range and there's tons of opportunity
but a nano influencer is somebody with
anywhere from 1,000 subscribers to
10,000 subscribers now there are many
stories in our community and some of our
peers uh of creators that can sometimes
get deals
uh most of the Waves we're talking about
have nothing to do with Brands but even
with less than a thousand there's some
opportunity but I think things really
get interesting as soon as you get to
that a thousand subscriber Mark and
here's what influencer marketing World
said they said that there's great news
for Nano and micro influencers right now
because they're becoming a larger part
of Brand's budgets as the industry
evolves so buckle your seat belt and
listen to this entire episode because
it's packed full of value to start
making money even if you have a small
Channel and today's episode is brought
to you by tube 1K challenge.com we have
our free upcoming 5-day challenge that's
actually all about how to get your first
or next 1 th000 subscribers and how to
generate your first or next $1,000 with
your YouTube channel it's entirely free
tell you a little bit more about that
later but you can check it up uh check
it out and register with the link in the
show notes so let's dive into number one
of our 12 different ways and that is
affiliate marketing now this is my
favorite way to start earning money when
you have a small ch Channel because the
barrier to entry is probably the lowest
out of all the different opportunities
you don't need to qualify for the
YouTube Partner program in some cases
you don't even need to have uploaded a
video yet there are affiliate programs
that will at least approve you to start
promoting and sharing links and earning
money if anyone clicks and buys anything
so it's a really cool way to get started
so we're on the same page what you do is
you sign up then you have to get
approved then you can start sharing your
specific links if someone clicks on that
and purchases something from that
website you get a commission so I signed
up for the Amazon Associates program on
my channel thick media where I review
cameras if I review a camera let's say
it's $1,000 I put an affiliate Link in
the description someone clicks that link
and purchases the camera I get 4% so I
would earn $4 off of that person
purchasing that camera and I love this
because I don't have to worry about
shipping or returns I don't have to
worry about setting up an e-commerce
store I really get to do a low amount of
work there's also kind of a app on
affiliate marketing if you think about
it I'm only earning 4% so as we cover
other money-making strategies this isn't
like the only in my opinion but it is a
good way to get started and in full
transparency if you want to get approved
for let's say the Amazon Associates
program there's usually a human
reviewing your application and chances
are you need some momentum I encourage
your channel has a cover it's branded
you probably have like 5 10 30 videos
uploaded some momentum there's no magic
number but you're getting some views
you've got some subscribers and so
there's certain programs that will deny
you but there's also programs that will
approve you even if you have again a
smaller Channel like I think about one
of our VRA students Lee from stray
reviews so he helps people find men's
lifestyle gear and his angle is like I'm
not just making lowquality videos off of
like a I wrote the script and I don't I
haven't tested the product his pitch is
these are real reviews not just
unboxings or repeating the manufacturing
description he actually tests and puts
the products to the test pass that
information along to the viewers and so
one of his videos best performing video
last year was the best mocko boots for
me Red Wing versus grandstone versus two
other brands he got 22,000 views he's
approved for Amazon and these specific
retailer websites so in some case these
mock toe boots are sold directly like
the grantstone website and then
sometimes they're maybe sold in multiple
places also on Amazon so he'll sign up
for all of the above his channel is
under 3,000 subscribers and in our
private group he was talking about
affiliate marketing it's been very
lucrative for me and I know that's not a
brand new channel but again he's in that
Nano influencer Arena so affiliate
marketing is a great way to get started
definitely subscribe and I'll link to a
playlist in the description of some of
our best affiliate marketing uh videos
and one specific strategy here is what
we call RSP this does naturally align
with RSP which stands for review
specific products so this strategy is
really great if you do a video that's
like what are the best X for your topic
like what are the best accessories for a
certain type of Fitness or what are the
best kitchen accessories so maybe not
every Niche can apply affiliate
marketing but I would argue 99% can if
it's software if it's physical products
if there's an eCommerce website of any
kind there's probably an affiliate
program and I'm actually going to be
teaching deeper about the RSP strategy
on our free challenge that's starting
soon at 21k challenge.com but let's go
to number two number two is brand deals
and sponsorships this is where you
partner with relevant Brands to your
channel topic to your personal brand to
feature their products or services in
your videos in exchange for payment or
free products or a combination of both
what's cool about brand deals and
sponsorships is what we mentioned at the
top of the episode brands are more than
ever working with micro and Nano
influenc fencers because rather than
let's say give $100,000 to a bigger
creator for a featured video they're
seeing that let's say they distributed
$1,000 each to 100 Nano influencers
they're able to then spread their
influence across a lot of different
creators kind of M mitigate downside
risk for themselves as a brand and what
they love about these smaller micro Nano
influencers is a lot of times they have
much more connected audiences maybe they
only have again less follow followers
but more passionate followers they are
able to more closely care for their
following because they don't have this
Mega following so they're very engaged
and maybe those creators hopefully you
are more open to maybe doing some
customization in terms of the content
you create for them and there's a lot of
other ways you could increase your pitch
value because it's not just based on
your influence maybe they want the
rights to be able to use the video you
make on their own website and make sure
you're subscribed because we're going to
be covering brand deals and sponsorships
in future episodes and some tactics but
that would be number two which leads us
to number three which is product
placements this is where you subtly
showcase relevant products within your
videos without directly promoting them
this is kind of a different angle of
brand deals and sponsorships and this
probably wouldn't be a one-off thing as
small crater does but this could be a
part of your pitch as you get educated
you start realizing it's not just
selling your influence right it's not
just selling I'll do a dedicated video
for you you might there's like 10 things
you could sell you could sell the
ability for making a video that they
could use on their website you could
sell the rights to do paid media maybe
they want to use your video in some kind
of an ad not only are you also promoting
their product but maybe they also want
even some Consulting creators as
consultants is a big Trend because you
they don't know even what you know like
they just know about their product and
they know they want to grow their
business but they're looking for your
expertise or the Creator's expertise to
create maybe a higher quality video with
them maybe they want to use that video
on their Amazon page you know how
there's videos on Amazon when you click
through all the images and the brands
commercial there's also like creators so
we'll be covering this in future
episodes but this is the thinking of
where a small Creator can start making
some good money because the only thing
you have leverage on is not just your
influence because you're like I only got
a th subscribers well there's like a lot
of other things you could include in
that pitch that could be helpful and
when it comes to product placements the
other big idea is maybe signing a three
or six Monon or year-long contract and
half of that might just be like you wear
our t-shirt or like we see the brand
logo in the background of you know the
shot or something and and that is
something that you've monetized a couple
tips here is one You definitely want to
work on your pitch to Brands and work on
your negotiation skills and then two
this is a powerful reason to also
overtime Network a little bit this is a
good use case for using Twitter X or
LinkedIn to start to get to know of
Brands you dream of working with someday
you can find the chief marketing officer
influencer marketing person maybe start
to network with them and it's a powerful
reason to go to strategic events cuz
sometimes getting face to face with the
people that works and work at Brands can
help you describe your unique value you
could add again Beyond just your amount
of subscribers your Maybe video
production capabilities or ability to
make a a raw authentic ad for them or
something like that which brings us to
number four and this is one of those
kind of new strategies that nobody is
talking about and it's creating you ugc
for Brands so there's a new term called
ugc creators now what does ugc mean it
stands for user generated content for
probably about a decade brands have
realized the power of this that maybe
you buy a sweatshirt or a Stanley mug or
something like that and you're putting
it on your Instagram stories you're
sharing it in your YouTube channel
you're you've promoted something as an
affiliate and done a product review and
you weren't paid by the brand but maybe
Brands reach out they follow a hashtag
they see where they're tagged they ask
for for permission because the user
created content they're like hey could
we use this could we feature you on our
Instagram page could we do that right
well there's a new way for small
creators to make money is actually
positioning themsel as a ugc Creator and
so really what it is is you're a Creator
that's in charge of promoting original
videos images reviews comments or other
forms of media a ugc Creator is a
content creator who specifically creates
content that looks like ugc but it's
been paid for unlike influencers who
actually to grow their Community before
they start working with Brands because
that's what you think right that's the
myth oh if I don't have 10,000 subs or
50,000 Brands don't want to work with me
ugc creators don't need a ton of
followers nor are they obligated even to
show their face because again these
Brands don't have the camera you have or
the smartphone you have or the skills
you have or the understanding of
marketing you have or hooks or angles or
storytelling and in one sense your
YouTube channel becomes more like a
portfolio than it becomes like a place
of influence at the start so your your
portfolio shows what you're capable of
and now you didn't believe you could be
paid $3,000 for a video well you can
because they're not paying for your
subscribers they'd be paying for the
video you're able to create for them and
so this is not technically organic like
ugc is but the reason ugc has worked so
well is because it's content created by
real fans so I think the thing here is
done ethically you're already a real fan
of a particular brand you've developed a
particular set of skills so in one sense
you're essentially a freelance content
creator that's being hired to create raw
content you know my wife and I are
watching Fargo season 5 it's unreal it's
a true story really good uh season and
we've been watching on Hulu and I don't
know if there's a higher level that I
could pay for where I don't get ads but
for some reason I just keep I still get
ads on Hulu and so I saw an ad recently
for hellofresh the subscription box
company and the way the ad looked on TV
I'm watching this on my Smart TV with my
wife was not like fancy cameras and like
overproduced content it was like a
compilation of cell phone shot content
of people opening their boxes in their
house people being like this is so tasty
this is so good and I have a feeling it
was all ugc creators because it had that
feeling of like raw organic product
review real people experience on the
product you know but at the same time it
was an ad on Hulu and so this is
something to think about that's out of
the box of what most people are talking
about will be covering this more in the
future as well and you can look up ugc
creators which brings us to number five
licensing your content and so this one's
a little bit more rare but it's all the
more relevant some of the biggest
stories of this for in our community
have been travel creators if you're
already traveling you're already on the
road you've already invested in a drone
you already have a GoPro or that's
something you're thinking about doing
it's not just upload your video to your
YouTube channel you went to all the the
work to fly there and film all the
crispy footage but you have to
understand the value of that footage
that could be licensed to somebody else
that wants to use that content this
takes a particular set of skills and
some networking and it might involve you
posting some things and then Brands
reaching out to you but for this one to
work you got to put a little hustle into
this figure this out but it again could
be very lucrative and if you start
thinking about the value of the content
itself another lesser talk about angle
on this is thinking about these stock
photography and videography websites if
you're great at filming clips of cool
stuff that other people would want to
use that b-roll that you may have used
in your own Vlog that early on you're
making like nothing for now you could
upload that to stock photography
videography websites like an iock photo
and if that's approved and if it's
downloaded you could earn money on that
and so that's number five number six is
fan funding this platforms like patreon
allow fans to support your channel on a
monthly basis is in exchange for
exclusive content or rewards I do
recommend patreon I think they take five
or up to 10% of however much money
you're earning another one is integrated
right into YouTube is what's called
Channel memberships they take 30% though
of the money and what's nice is it's the
convenience the infrastructure that
YouTube provides you people don't have
to leave the platform but there's also
the economic aspects I think that if
your channel is small and you're even in
that Nano influence range the mistake
here is investing I think too much
energy to get like two people supporting
you at $5 a month that $10 is great but
that's my only caution is that if you're
going to launch fan funding it's a topic
for another episode I would say do it
right and do it at a particular Tipping
Point because again just reverse
engineer it even if you were earning $50
or $100 a month from
patreon like it all helps but the way my
mindset was when I was starting and
waiting tables at Red Robin and doing my
YouTube hustle uh side hustle was I was
like man I can just earn more money
getting more tips from waiting tables at
Red Robin and pay my bills that way why
focusing on building my influence up as
opposed to just launching something
prematurely so when it comes to Fan
funding I just think there's a certain
point when you should launch it some
people do it too early I think that's
the biggest mistake but here's one of
our new monetization updates so YouTube
in 2023 lowered the bar to entry for the
YouTube Partner program by offering an
earlier or reduced route to getting in
the program so now you only need 500
subscribers three videos published in
the last 90 days and either 3,000 hours
of watch time in the past year or 3
million YouTube shorts views in the past
90 days so they lowered the barrier to
entry now you could get in the program
you apply you have to be in a country
that is a part of the program um where
you need to live where it's actually
available but this does not give you to
ads on your access to ads on your videos
but it does give you Channel memberships
so now you could have people pay for
premium content and member perks super
chats and super stickers which this is
where you gives fans the ability to live
chat and do an animated image that pops
up paid typically this is on live
streams or if you premere your videos
and then Super thanks you can generate
view uh revenue from viewers who want to
show Extra thanks for your content these
come in on our channels if we add
massive value in videos I get like a$2
in a way like a tip or a $5 tip and
again it's just super cool if you have a
really deep dive Channel you're building
up that adds value to viewers once you
cross this threshold of 500 subscribers
3,000 watchtime hours you can start
getting super thanks and you also unlock
the ability to promote merch through
YouTube shopping which is a new feature
on YouTube that's integrated with like
six different surfaces a shelf on shorts
a particular product highlighted on
shorts a shelf below videos different
aspects there so that's kind of cool but
to actually get ads running on your
videos the requirements are still the
same 1,000 subscribers 4,000 hours of
watch time in the last 12 months or
1,000 subscribers with 10 million valid
public shorts views in the last 90 days
you still have to jump through those
hurdles to um get ads on your videos but
it is cool that the qualifications have
been lowered which just gives us again
even more opportunity in a 2024 World
which brings us to number seven which is
ADD sense Revenue now this one's
probably obvious for you and one of the
reasons why you're on this podcast
episode is because you're like okay I
have a small Channel I'm not approved
for the partner program yet but once you
do get approved for it of course this is
a cool way that a nano influencer 1,000
subscribers you hit the watchtime
threshold boom now AdSense is a stream
of income once you're approved and we
will be talking about I think the
fundamental problem that you face is
Sean how do I get more subscribers and
how do I get more views because even
though it's possible to make money with
a small channel the goal shouldn't be to
stay small you don't need a huge channel
to make big money but of course all of
our goal is to get monetized and so I
highly recommend that you join me for
our free 5-day challenge where we're
going to be going through deep dive
training daily challenges to get you
taking action and reaching your goals
and stretching outside of your comfort
zone tons of giveaways it's going to be
really fun it's entirely free if you go
to tube 1K challenge.com you can
register there is like a VIP upgrade
where you can get some uh private Q&A
with me in a much smaller group there's
an upgrade to uh our starter kit but
whether those things are right for you
or not go to tube 1K challenge.com or
click the Link in the show notes to
register because again five days deep
dive content entirely free and it's up
to you if you want to do the upgrades
but let's go into number eight which is
freelance work so if you're a small
channel one of the things you could do
is leverage your YouTube presence to
attract freelance clients for anything
video editing graphic design writing or
other skills you possess now this might
not be relevant for your particular
style of Channel um but here's the
framework I like to recommend if you
have some kind of service or freelance
offering your channel could teach how to
like you could give away information of
how to do the thing for free but then
you also could Market the done for you
and what's cool is over time you can now
start earning money on multiple fronts
like let's say example the skill of
copywriting which is writing persuasive
marketing copy on social media and
emails to drive sales for a business or
a brand well let's say your YouTube
channel was actually about how small
businesses could write their own copy
and the best principles for copywriting
but then what you mention is you're like
and by the way if this sounds like a lot
of work or like you don't feel like you
have the time you can always hire me to
do that work for you so you could give
away free information on uh graphic
design and how to use canva and you also
say and I also have freelance Services
that'd be like one way to think about it
and this could work into our ninth way
of making money which is also coaching
and Consulting so you could use your
expertise to offer one-on-one group grp
coaching or services to your viewers it
reminds me of Nicole from kids OT help
um one of our early video raik Academy
students who has such a wild story about
starting her YouTube channel scaling it
up not just having massive success in
building a big business on her Channel
but eventually her Channel being
acquired like her brand and business
being acquired
by corporate's kind of the wrong word
but by a brand like a a brand for kids
and then that her hiring her back and
her ultimately becoming a million dooll
generating Creator through all of these
seasons and phases of content creation
which I hope also maybe points a picture
for your own Journey like I want to
encourage you to get started scale up
grow you never know what doors of
opportunity are going to open for you on
the other side of being consistent and
leveling up your skills well all the way
back when Nicole started to kind of be
at the Early Middle stage of her career
one of the things she offered on her own
website was just a private kids OT
session so OT is occupational therapy um
in this case occupational therapy that
helps kids play improve their school
performance AIDS and daily activities
and she charged $150 for a 30-minute
consultation which she could do
virtually so originally I believe she
was in an outpatient clinic but then she
realized I have these skills and I want
to have a life and business on my own
own terms and I see the power of YouTube
so she started creating content and she
started to do affiliate marketing might
have been a video about certain toys for
learning for kids and or best uh best
toys or school activities or accessories
that you could outfit a room at home to
create a learning environment and a play
environment cool so that's a video with
affiliate marketing eventually she got
monetized cool there's ad Revenue coming
in she started doing brand deals and
sponsorships cool that was coming in in
terms of people wanting to get in front
of her audience even when she was a
smaller Creator and she then was also
able to do coaching and Consulting is
just another opportunity and it's not
like that was like the phone was ringing
off the hook or tons of people were
buying that but one of the things to
consider as you build out your whole
online platform is what links are on
your YouTube channel where else are you
sending people I don't think you need a
website day one but maybe someday you
have a website set up and all you need
to ultimately be able to do this is you
could actually just do like a
paypal.me forward you know Sean canel
and I could say hey pay me some money
and I'll do some coaching or Consulting
with you which I did early on um back
when I was charging like a hundred or300
or $500 an hour uh early on because I
had some video skills these days the
number is much higher that is number
nine coaching or Consulting and as a
side note I uploaded a episode about the
biggest Trends or it's coming soon and
one of the trends that is happening in
2024 is creators as consultants so
brands are increasingly using
influencers for Creative input into
product development creation of content
for the brand to use on their own
channels and their paid advertising as
well as creating a community of
customers with influencers providing an
effective interface between Brands and
Their audience so this is a big Trend
and small channels are underestimating
the opportunity to work with I think
even big Brands let me give you an
example I was recently bought uh a
couple SUVs at a local Toyota dealership
and really my wife uh got two cars and I
got none isn't that how it goes no I'm
pumped about it but we got like a Toyota
Toyota Sequoia TRD got a Toyota 4Runner
big Toyota family now and I actually
when talking to our rep sales rep they
heard about what I did and they're like
man I got to introduce you to um the
owner of the dealership and like the
marketing person well as I sat down with
them what I started to just over coffee
just friendly conversation was I started
to say you know if I was you I would
look for and connect with influencers of
all sizes in the Pacific Northwest
region up the I5 Corridor um now I have
a particular set of skills they're like
where would we find them how would cuz
they they don't even know that so that
speaks to you got to be aware of like
who your audience is but I was like you
should work with I know of a crater
that's kind of more in the Arlington
Washington area more of a lifestyle and
I was kind of like she's not huge but I
was like give her a car lend her a car
and pay for her trip to like go over the
mountains to lenworth Washington film
footage along the way again kind of to
that ugc Creator level of like even if
it's not her influence that drives
anyone to your dealership now you have
the content but also what if you create
a community of these different content
creators that are in the local region
and so creators as consultant or
coaching and Consulting I think is just
something to think about this one might
be like not the most practical one for
you at this exact moment but the future
is bright and why can't you be the go-to
expert in your circle or why can't you
be the go-to expert in your city or your
Niche category again we're
underestimating the opportunity to work
for like a local local dealership and
find some ways to maybe exchange some
money exchange some value create some
opportunities and I want to encourage
you to again start small where you might
be like well I need money and a and a
and a borrowing a car is not going to be
that helpful but you're creating a
relationship so even if you could do
some free value you know a free stay
food the goal isn't just that one thing
the goal is to demonstrate in your
portfolio what you're capable of them to
see the ROI and that can lead to the
next thing that builds your portfolio up
you can then the next brand is a paid
deal or now you're stepping in the game
at 500 bucks then a couple thousand Etc
which brings us to number 10 digital
products so with a small Channel you
could create or sell ebooks online
courses templates other digital products
related to your
Niche one of our VRA students Commander
hay is a card fighter and so there's
these different card games that people
people are playing
competitively well he ended up writing a
book a high quality book he worked with
an agency but on how to win card fight
tournaments and I asked him about it he
said the book hit bestseller release on
when he released it 100 plus copies sold
in 1.5 weeks of release uh he actually
worked with a friend of ours and we'll
link to that episode if you've ever
thought about writing a book where I did
an interview with my friend Chandler
bolt and we can link that up in the show
notes he has a company called uh
self-publishing school and so that's
pretty cool now hay has packaged what he
knows in a book and check this out he
said 100 sold in the first one and a
half weeks of release now they're kind
of trickling in but he's really it's a
over 200 Page book I mean it's tactics
strategy of all these different
approaches to building your deck winning
card fighting tournament once you've
created something to sell you can keep
selling it for weeks months and years to
come so what's nice is as a small
Channel when you create your own product
your own ebook your own online course
your own templates you could keep
selling that um for years to come and
similarly I mentioned Nicole earlier she
did the same thing now we're stacking we
call this YouTube income stacking and
Commander hay he's under 3,000
subscribers he's a nano Creator he's
approved for the partner program now and
so he's stacking these things up and
this is how you go to from making
hundreds a month to thousands month I
remember when Omar elori on his personal
Channel made a video about taking family
photography his expertise is many things
but photography was one and in the video
he sold his own Photoshop Lightroom
presets for just quickly making your
photos look awesome well he ranked a
video which means he made the video one
time but it kept being found in Search
and kept being suggested and from that
one video saying and by the way if you
want to buy my Lightroom presets for I
think 10 or $20 you could just plug
these right into you know your next
batch shoot and save tons of time so
valuable so it's you start thinking
about as you learn even just sales of
presentation why is it worth $10 or $20
are you kidding like that's how much I'm
going to spend at Wendy's later you know
and so if I could save 30 minutes or an
hour and on my consecutive upcoming
photo shoots and have my photos look
better than ever and get a particular
vibe to them so that's a true digital
product it's literally a digital file
that people purchase and then install in
software I remember him recounting that
him and his wife Amanda were able to pay
their morgage for a couple months he
earned a couple thousand dollars and
then eventually the TR the the video you
know kind of trailed off in its views
and he didn't continue to really promote
it uh as he has done multiple things and
launched his new show and still does
some stuff at think media what's the
point digital products and so as a small
Creator I would go heavy on this one my
caution is that that there's only so
much time in a day and you're probably
learning how do I post videos and learn
thumbnails and learn all this different
stuff and then like also create a book
or also create templates or also create
but there's sequencing to this you're
not going to do it all in one day but
you could accomplish a lot over the next
six months and what could you do over
the next couple years so I would
encourage a lot of people to be uh
serious about digital products because
it really empowers you to not be
dependent on revenue or brands or some
of these other things but it sort of
like just gives you more Tools in your
tool belt for earning money and one of
the
most untalked
about ways of earning pretty significant
money is promoting somebody else's
digital product as an affiliate in the
industry it's called JV Partners or
joint venture
partners and you could probably promote
almost any digital product but for
example if it's somebody's online course
or their coaching program or their event
a lot of times the affiliate split is
like 50% so if somebody had like an
$1,000 online course or $500 think about
that 50% of that is $250 on a $500
course and before you take the time to
go make a course or you take the time to
figure out how to Market and promote it
or you do all of that if it's aligned
with your Niche or aligned with your
audience or aligned with part of your
audience one of our video ra Academy
students are remember they said I've
only been two weeks into your course and
I've already done two ,000 in affiliate
commissions pretty cool what they
attached that to though was a screenshot
of the vid IQ stats of how many views
their entire Channel had gotten and it
was 1,500 views now let's do the math
together on the podcast their entire
Channel had only gotten
1,500 views if you've uploaded a YouTube
short you know that like oh yeah I can
get like 1,500 even if it wasn't that
good like I got a couple shorts so it's
not that much views and yet he had
already earned 2,000 th000 that's how we
want you to be thinking and we call our
think media podcast think media we want
you to think different think bigger
think outside of the box and a lot of
times the reason smaller channels suffer
is because of a lack of information a
lack of knowing and connecting the dots
again sometimes there's some shady stuff
and lowquality online courses out there
like I I'm not ignorant to that but if
you find the right product from the
right person that's rightly aligned with
your audience that's truly remarkable
that really gets the result and delers
on the promise and the whole thing is
all lined up you do your due diligence
there are some people who built entire
businesses off of just being JV partners
and they like the leverage they think
about doing the customer service and the
building out of an online course it's a
lot of work by promoting others that
you're aligned with you know one other
example would be like let's say you had
a running Channel well there's like
Marathon preparedness programs my
stepbrother Alan escin did an Iron Man
and so he actually invested quite a bit
of money in someone's educational online
course and coaching program to prepare
for an Iron Man no small feet and he was
not only financially able to pay for a
pretty expensive program but again
imagine if you were doing Fitness
marathons ultramarathons or something
even kind of adjacent to that and it
made sense for you to make a video rank
a video and promote that person's thing
because maybe you're like yeah I've done
some athletic events like that but I
don't really have a program like I don't
know the nutrition and all the different
stuff and so maybe it's something you've
personally that's probably the best
you've personally taken that course well
again let's say the program's five grand
if you get 25% you know it's over $1,000
so something to look into and then
definitely subscribe to the podcast
because we'll be covering more of that
in the future as well and here's the the
statistic the global e-learning market
AKA online courses online learning is
expected to hit $1 trillion by
2032 a trillion dollar that's the total
addressable market so this whole world
of digital products of people leaning in
to the power of e-learning being able to
from from home learn new skills learn
specialty skills not have to get on a
plight fight flight a flight and pay for
a hotel room and airline tickets and all
this other stuff it's massive and it's
growing and it's going to be like
doubling over the next like eight years
according to the stats and so you
learning and sharpening your skills now
positioning your Channel Growing your
Channel it's nice just having this in in
your tool belt maybe there's not a joint
venture partner that makes sense at this
moment you knowing about this will give
you an advantage over the coming not
just months but years which brings us to
number 11 physical products so you can
design and sell branded t-shirts mugs
phone cases and other items to your fans
and then you could also think outside of
the box so I think about Mike Quist from
stonecoat countertops a very interesting
story by the way of someone who also
started their Channel grew their Channel
their Channel and kind of business was
eventually acquired for a significant
ific amount of money so cool to see what
is maturing in the crater economy we're
talking about people who are at like not
the end of their career but almost like
the jumping point it's the end of us
season into the next season but I know
our conversation here is for small
channels again I want to encourage you
you're not exiting your YouTube channel
or creating any Enterprise Value on it
day one but what's your vision for your
brand what could you build and one of
the things that Mike did was originally
they had a business in Oregon installing
epoxy countertops in people's homes so
they're going out doing jobs got a team
and as a alternative to proper granite
countertops or this or that form of
countertops they could install count
epoxy countertops well starts a YouTube
channel starts to do free videos to show
people how to DIY do-it-yourself
countertop installs but on his website
if you wanted you could buy an epoxy
countertop kit with the various colors
that you're going to put in there to
swirl the effect or to give a granite
like look or marble like look and you
can watch the free videos on his YouTube
channel but then go to his website and
pay him to ship you an epoxy countertop
kit so this idea of physical products
offers a lot of opportunity for the
small channel if you start leaning into
what is the buy button that is going to
exist somewhere around your YouTube
channel or on your own website I've
learned that ultimately in online
business your income is directly
correlated to the amount of buy buttons
you have on your website that might
cause you to pause and say I have zero
buy buttons on my website Sean and I
also don't even have a website so you're
like okay well day one you're not you're
not going to probably build out an epoxy
countertop install business and have
this whole kit but I found that those
that are most successful think bigger
than AdSense I would recommend that day
one you don't necessarily build a
physical product but day one you could
be thinking about it man someday I would
love to sell my own version of this
accessory or this kitchen accessory or
this Fitness accessory or this ham radio
thing like there's a lot of things and
that could be a part of your vision that
could be lucrative really later on I
also realized that I wrote 13 of these
not just 12 so I've got a Bonus one
coming up for you in just a second and
as a reminder on this super long episode
of the think media podcast and we got
more to cover if you want to learn more
about all of the above in particularly
get getting more views subscribers check
out tube 1K challenge.com and uh let me
finish and then we'll land the plane on
that so number 12 is to generate leads
and clients for your existing business
now you got a small Channel this is
probably one of the best ways to earn
money so maybe you have an existing
business company or agency couple
examples maybe network marketing Mary
Kay makeup or skincare dotera essential
oils which I personally buy from a
distributor and I love now I know that
sometimes network marketing gets a bad
rap I think the mistake there is it's
usually if the product was bad and the
company was sketchy and and that there's
those stories but I also think it
sometimes is there's an overly negative
connotation there think about dotera or
Mary Kay these are incredibly reputable
brands with products that people love so
if there's a product you love you now
have the ability to earn money off the
products through your YouTube videos and
it's kind of like affiliate marketing
but different because now you have your
own store your own thing and you've got
the ability to build your team your
downline right so if it's a product you
love and a company you believe in I
think it's actually one of the most
slept on opportunities and I think if
you're a nano influencer that is in say
health and wellness well there's tons of
Health and Wellness if you're a nano
influencer in in skincare
anti-aging or if you're giving advice to
women in their 40s or women in their
50s the Synergy between network
marketing and your YouTube channel could
be massive the cool thing about network
marketing is is you do learn a lot of
business skills and you are empowered
with if you will your own products with
a a compensation structure so there's a
lot of due diligence for you to do there
and I'm not telling you to just blindly
rush into whatever on a product you
don't love and a company you don't
believe in but I think that's one
opportunity now
another way to generate leads and
clients for your business could apply to
real estate right real estate agents or
the real estate industry Brokers when
you've got the
opportunity to do housing transactions
you know I think of affil of real estate
agents as like high ticket affiliate
marketers here's what I mean if you had
a YouTube channel that brought you in a
lead that ended up buying a million
dollar house and you get 3% commission
you know I get 4% on cameras you get 3%
on the house we just made $30,000 off of
one transaction when you start tapping
into thinking like that YouTube
plus a more solid business model like
real estate or Professional Services
accounting legal marketing consulting
firms if your YouTube channel is lead
gen for people signing up for some kind
of Professional Service again you could
make big money with a small Channel if
you're a business owner you have an
agency so like jend Devore RoR when she
had 546 subscribers she sent us an email
she joined our program video ra Academy
she sent us an email she said I just had
my biggest week ever in new business I
generated $1,000 in new business in one
week
from following what you guys teach now
mind you she does marketing services for
businesses so that was where the
income's coming from ad Revenue off of a
channel her size is number one she's not
even approved for the partner program
and even if she was she's going to get
like $10 $50 those types of numbers well
you tap into number 12 leads and clients
for an existing business and you figure
out what that business is then you could
start generating big money and it's a
different mindset YouTube becomes a tool
for your business not the business
itself so it's almost like I think
categorically there's entertainment
channels there's education channels
there's YouTube being the business
itself ad Revenue the channel
memberships you can make a great
business off of Just YouTube paying you
meaning they cut you the AdSense checks
you have some Channel membership
subscribers people give you super chats
people do YouTube shopping like they've
created an ecosystem on YouTube that's
one model the other model though is like
YouTube is marketing and Lead gen for a
different business I think the
conclusion there is you getting
self-awareness and charting a path and
you might have pivots over on your
journey but I love this number 12 one
because I never want to be dependent on
a platform alone I the future is bright
for YouTube I think it's not only it is
the dominant video platform but I think
the next decade is going to be the best
decade on YouTube and it's a good
platform to plant your flag on but you
want diversification that's why we also
en encourage building an email list
don't do all of the above all at once
but this is why SMS text messaging
having a community there or building a
Discord group or a Facebook group
diversifying your audience off of your
platform is a smart move building up
newsletters could be lucrative as a
whole thing that's a whole another deal
uh didn't leave you put it in the list
but not only do you have the newsletter
how you can you monetize the newsletter
but but you could keep talking to the
newsletter even if the algorithm changed
or you had an issue with your YouTube
channel so number 12 is generate leads
clients for your business and then
number 13 is use your talent as a video
creator for another brand or business so
essentially pitch yourself to be hired
by a brand let me give you an example no
one's talking about this but again
you're a small channel so what have you
done you've developed skills you might
be early but you want want to talk on
camera you have learn started to learn
video editing maybe you've been a small
channel for a long time you haven't been
able to break through but the skills
you've developed so Trisha
hersberger works for Kingston technology
she's been doing it for a long year so
Kingston technology has like memory
sticks Ram all this different products
they sell well if you go to their
Channel you'll see that she is like a
host of a brand who I couldn't tell you
the face behind the brand and I think
there's multiple creators on the channel
but she's been like a pillar and she
also has her own channel yet she's been
working for Kingston for years I don't
know the terms of the agreement but
apparently it's been a win-win because
they've been going for years she creates
content on her own channel she's also
hired by another Channel and again maybe
she loves it uh maybe her main Channel
if you will doesn't pay enough or what
her financial aspirations are so she
also has this other opportunity bring
this much more closer to home from
someone I do know one of our VRA
students ER from monzon media got hired
by plague ground AI which is an app and
software product that does um really
cool photo editing replace the
background you know you take a picture
you're just in your office now you're in
like a jungle with the power of AI and
all this different stuff well playground
AI has their own YouTube channel manur
also has his own channel but what
happened was he was able to and we did a
whole V show about it which is a monthly
show inside of our community where our
our students like break down all this
kind of stuff but playground AI hired
him and that became a very lucrative
full-time opportunity for him to create
content for another brand and so here's
what you need to know Brands and
businesses lack content creator skills
they're often terrible at marketing and
they don't want to be on camera when I
was at the Toyota dealership I was
talking to them I said here's what I
would do is if I was you one identify if
there's someone on your current staff
that could start being creating content
for your own channel or your own social
platforms is there somebody you could
test they've got the Charisma they
they've got whatever now but the problem
with that is kind of risky and you don't
if they've never done it there's no they
have no idea but the people at that
Toyota dealership they're looking at me
like dude we have nobody we don't have
content creator skills we don't know
what to do we don't know best practices
so imagine if you're connected to the
think media podcast Community you're a
few months and years into this you've
invested in yourself you leveled up your
skills it's like Brands want this I'm
not saying it's easy to maybe make the
connections but this is going to be a
wave in the next 5 to 10 years of Brands
hiring
individuals that maybe your channel
hasn't broken through yet but you have
the opportunity to come on staff in a
contractor basis one video maybe you do
four videos a month one a week for them
maybe you're paid per video but you can
look it up so if you look at playground
AI you're going to see man as the
Creator for the channel and what you're
looking for is alignment here because
he's already kind of a an AI software
geek there's kind of a overlap on his
own channel with that channel which is
the best case scenario right maybe
you're passionate about a particular
vertical building up your channel and
there's a brand that's like we need the
talent I think that's what to see
yourself as somebody who could create
videos for us be a face for us because
they might have 50 people on staff and
none of them want to do the YouTube
channel so that could be an interesting
opportunity that I believe is really
existing in a uh 2024 and Beyond world
so here's what the action item becomes
Lear learn digital marketing learn
content creator skills develop your
camera and your confidence skills if
you're open-minded I believe that
fulltime on YouTube could be a lot
closer than you think but it also might
be different than you think we've
covered 13 different ways of earning
money as a small Creator a small Channel
a nano influencer a micro influencer and
a lot of these could start right away
but who knows maybe you could lock in a
talent opportunity with a brand with
another business start creating content
from them but that's only if you
actually have those skills and honestly
I think that this is actually one of the
biggest opportunities for small creators
in 2024 and really the next decade is
the opportunity that Brands and
businesses are looking for talent
they're looking for someone that they
could hire to create content for them
maybe as a ugc Creator or actually as a
regular Creator that's on their channel
in the example of Trisha herburger and
Kingston or man and monzon media and
playground AI but here is the next move
you got to develop the skills and at
thick media podcast that's what we
always encourage you to do always get 1%
better with every upload learn digital
marketing learn social media marketing
learn YouTube best practices and learn
content creator skills communication
persuasion video editing develop your
camera and your confidence skills if
you're a business owner you already got
a a business you're not worried about
being hired by another business but I
hope that this episode shows that every
creator has different approaches to this
and on the other side of you getting
better and improving your skills if
you're open-minded I think full-time
could be a lot closer than you think but
it might look different than you think
you might be able to be fulltime in the
next month why because like man you get
hired by playground Ai and that gives
you a place where yes you're creating
consistent content for another business
or brand but then two you're also able
to work on your own channel in the
process the next three years are going
to be the best three years in the crater
economy according to Goldman Sachs
research what they said is that by 2027
the total addressable Market the Creator
economy could be a half a trillion
dollar industry essentially doubling in
the next three years so massive momentum
is coming to this industry there's a lot
of intangibles it's not without risk
it's not without challenges it's not
without a skill Gap that you need to
close as you continue to level up but we
do know this fact there is massive
momentum happening and so get committed
lean in get disciplined stop dabbling
start dominating and really lean in and
I hope that you've learned a lot from
these 13 different ways of earning money
and if You' love this kind of content I
want to invite you to tube 1K
challenge.com because it's going to give
us even more time to go deeper in all of
these monetization methods but more
importantly let's grow your influence
let's get you more views let's get you
to your first first 1,000 subscribers or
your next and let's talk about
practically how can you earn your first
$1,000 these are the different
methodologies but let's close that Gap
and get that first a th as soon as
possible that's what tube 1ky challenge
is all about we're giving away some
cameras we're giving away a complete
YouTube Studio it's a super fun thing
that we only do a couple times a year so
check out the show notes 21k
challenge.com and if you enjoy this
episode like rate review or share the
podcast wherever you listen or watch and
if you're on YouTu YouTu let me know
your favorite out of the 13 ways of
money making money the one you're going
to lean into and any future questions
that you have that you'd love covered in
future episodes is there one of these
that you'd love for me to go deeper on
is there questions about these you have
specific questions about that's what
this podcast is for helping you in on
YouTube and so I can't wait to connect
with you in a future episode until then
my name is Sean canel rhymes with
YouTube channel this is the think media
podcast and we'll talk soon